est-ce ce matin je vais aller voter pour
la première fois est-ce que tu veux
m'accompagner ouais avec plaisir parce
que moi je dois attendre encore quelques
années avant de pouvoir voter à tout à
fait en France pour disposer du droit de
vote il faut avoir 18 ans et être
citoyen français un européen peut voter
aux élections municipales et européenne
si son pays fait partie de l'Union
européenne d'accord mais au fait
pourquoi est-ce qu'on va voter très
bonne question voter ça consiste à
choisir ses représentants comme son
maire son député ou le président de la
République
en fait le pays les régions les villes
les villages ne sont pas directement
dirigées par le peuple mais par des
représentants élus par lui c'est ce
qu'on appelle la démocratie
représentative et bien moi avant de
voter je vais bien réfléchir et je ne
serai influencé ni par mes amis ni par
les réseaux sociaux ni même par toi même
si tu es mon grand frère tu fais bien
allez on arrive dans le bureau de vote
c'est bon j'ai bien ma carte d'identité
et ma carte électorale
tu vois sur les grandes tables il y a
des bulletins de tous les candidats dans
notre village il y a autant d'hommes que
de femmes qui se présentent et il y a
six partis politiques
oh c'est drôle les isoloirs je les
imaginais pas du tout comme ça et ben
oui en fait il ressemble à des cachettes
secrètes comme ça personne ne sait pour
qui tu votes on dit que le suffrage est
secret et ensuite quand tu sors de
l'isoloir tu vas glisser ton enveloppe
dans l'urne
c'est déjà fini et oui regarde ma carte
elle est en poney à la date de
l'élection